les forums des associations vont se
tenir principalement durant ce week-end
c'est la tradition chaque année au début
du mois de septembre l'occasion de
donner au sein continent aux yvelinois
aux Français d'aller s'inscrire pour
participer 10 participants et notamment
à des clubs sportifs et y aura-t-il un
effet JO c'est la question que nous
allons poser à nos invités André Gallia
bonsoir vous êtes président de la ligue
de judo du département et puis Jean qui
est là président de l'ASMB basket
l'association de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
donc spécialisé en basket y aura-t-il un
effet géo est-ce que régulièrement il y
a un effet Jo est-ce que vous l'avez
constaté en judo par exemple avec les
succès de Teddy Riner notamment pour
prendre citer que lui oui quand même il
y a toujours un petit succès mais ceci
étant quand il y a eu les Jeux
olympiques à Athènes malgré les mauvais
résultats nous avons continué à nous
développer donc cette discipline c'est
quelque chose de fantastique puisque
nous veillons véhiculons les valeurs
éducatives et sportives et morale bien
sûr alors j'ai cité Teddy Riner faut
surtout pas que j'oublie lucide Écosse
également
de 70 kg et puis Teddy Riner un
quintuple champion du monde champion
olympique en plus de 100 kg alors vous
nous disiez que le judo en fait les
Français ils sont fidèles il y a
toujours beaucoup d'inscription beaucoup
d'inscription alors pour la petite
histoire les Yvelines on est le premier
département francilien avec 17300
adhérents on a fait plus 400 et quelques
cadran par rapport à la saison dernière
donc on espère encore évoluer donc ce
qui nous manque bien sûr c'est un outil
de travail c'est un dojo régional et
donc plusieurs années de plusieurs
apparemment la communauté
d'agglomération c'est décidé du projet
donc on repart à la case départ
malheureusement je ne savais pas quand
ni où ce dojo pourrait voir le jour non
mais c'est à dire que on a deux deux
communes qui sont proposées Les Mureaux
et puis ça retrouve ville mais donc
c'est a tenu jusqu'à la saison dernière
jusqu'au moment où la communauté
d'agglomération c'est des systèmes de ce
projet sur lequel nous avons beaucoup
travaillé malheureusement mais bon c'est
ça un projet ça aboutit ou ça ça
n'aboutit pas mais on perd pas l'espoir
en tout cas ça n'empêche pas les
adhérents de venir s'inscrire ils sont
sans doute nombreux à venir lors des
forums des associations s'inscrire dans
des clubs de judo grâce au succès des
Tricolores on va parler du basket aussi
avec vous mais juste toujours à propos
du judo nous sommes allés rencontrer
Loïc brigand il est président lui de
l'ASMB Montigny-le-Bretonneux mais judo
voici ce qu'il nous a dit concernant les
inscriptions les inscriptions sont club
de judo des inscriptions qui sont en
hausse vous allez le voir il va nous le
confirmer on écoute le brigand
on a déjà commencé à le voir la saison
dernière alors que nous étions stables
et puis six sept ans autour de 250
adhérents l'année dernière déjà on a
augmenté de 10% les effectifs des
adhérents je pense qu'il y avait déjà un
effet Teddy Riner et Lucie d'Écosse qui
ont été championne du monde là l'année
dernière donc je pense que cette année
aux Jeux olympiques et au nombre de coup
de fil que je commence déjà à recevoir
pour des renseignements pour les
inscriptions je pense qu'on devrait
avoir une petite augmentation comme
cette saison quoi j'ai vécu l'époque la
grande époque de Douillet quand il était
champion olympique Atlanta donc il avait
déjà été champion du monde l'année
précédente et champion du monde l'année
suivante et là on avait augmenté de 200
adhérents au moins
les effectifs à cette époque là et après
ça c'est ça c'est un peu tassé alors il
y a bien un effet JO avec les succès
effectivement en tout cas dans ce club
là dont il bretonneuse les inscriptions
sont augmentées en flèche à chaque fois
notamment avec David Douillet et il y a
une heure depuis plusieurs années est-ce
que du côté du basket alors c'est votre
collègue puisqu'il s'occupe de Montigny
et vous vous occupez du basket est-ce
que du côté du basket des inscriptions
sont déjà en hausse aussi bien du côté
basket homme mais aussi du basket
féminin parce que les féminines ont
ramené une médaille une médaille
d'argent les hommes n'ont pas réussi à
battre l'Espagne les rivaux éternels
c'est surtout en garçon qu'on a pas
réussi
on a pas réussi à battre les États-Unis
non plus la barre c'était un peu trop
haute mais c'est vrai que nous deux
équipes de France ont fait un très beau
parcours et on peut s'attendre comme on
a pu le constater précédemment dans
d'autres sports collectifs comme le
football le rugby ou handball une
augmentation de nos adhérents alors on
l'a pas encore trop ressenti dans les
semaines qui viennent de passer on
l'attend plus tôt au niveau du forum
samedi
principalement dans les équipes
féminines comme vous le disiez c'est
l'équipe féminine quand même eu la
médaille d'argent donc la un très beau
challenge réussi et d'autant plus que
c'est en fille que l'on manque un petit
peu d'effectif en garçon on est quand
même généralement assez complet par
contre en fille on a toujours un peu de
problèmes à combler nos équipes je
dirais et si on peut avoir de nouvelles
joueuses en basket on sera très très
content pour continuer nos équipes
seniors qui malheureusement
limité autour de 300 et 340 licenciés
par an sachant que nous créneaux
d'entraînements sont complets
pratiquement de 17 heures à 22h30 tous
les soirs dans le gymnase là encore nous
parle pas de dojo mais on aura un
gymnase de plus
Israël bienvenu par contre en équipe
féminine je disais on a de de des
effectifs qui sont moindres et on peut
absorber de nouvelles inscriptions sans
trop de problèmes
dans les équipes de jeunes
principalement quoi quel impact pour le
basket féminin nous sommes allés poser
la question à l'un des spécialistes
peut-être de ce domaine sur le
département des Yvelines Olivier Mazet
c'est un agent de joueurs il est
installé dans les Yvelines il s'occupe
de la carrière dans des piliers de cette
équipe de France féminine de basket
Emilie Gomis forcément nous lui avons
demandé si c'est bon résultat pouvait
avoir un impact sur les inscriptions en
club
le grand public a pu voir que voilà il y
avait des valeurs c'est des valeurs
pardon qui étaient prenaient tout à fait
intéressantes le mixité enthousiasme
d'envie de de partage de collectif qui
je pense à mon avis sont très très
importantes dans la perception des des
parents par rapport à leurs enfants dans
tel ou tel sport je pense qu'elles ont
amener vraiment de la fraîcheur et elles
ont montré de l'envie apporter ce
maillot et au basket donc je pense que
c'est ça peut avoir des vrais
répercussions
alors forcément il y aura une
conséquence forcément les joueuses vont
venir du côté du basket féminin
forcément il y aura du monde du côté du
judo vous pouvez absorber plus ou moins
séos mais est-ce qu'ensuite c'est c'est
durable est-ce que le soufflet retombe
pas un peu trop vite aussi il y a des
désillusions parfois disons que c'est
vrai que ça a pas été forcément constaté
dans l'autre sport par exemple le rugby
en 2007 avec la Coupe du Monde qui s'est
déroulée en France effectivement
augmenté ils ont ils ont maintenu on
espère nous que dans les catégories
féminines on pourra les maintenir bon il
est vrai que parfois surtout chez les
jeunes ils essayent un sport parce
qu'ils l'ont vu pendant quelques
semaines à la télé avec un certain
nombre de résultats et après il y a un
petit phénomène d'usure à nous de les
fidéliser de leur faire adhérer leur
faire aimer le sport pour qu'ils
puissent persévérer et aller dans les
équipes seniors et continuer comme ça
sur plusieurs années quoi du côté du
judo même maintenant
tous les ans on progresse un petit peu
alors cette fidélité au judo c'est c'est
ancré dans les traditions français une
nouvelle c'est que nous venons de
franchir le cap des 600 000 judoka en
c'est tout récent et alors justement ça
veut dire que tout au long de l'année il
faut travailler vous nous disiez faut
les fidéliser mais est-ce que vous
œuvrez par exemple au judo pour les
fidéliser et comment c'est surtout le
dit de nos professeurs de nos
enseignants et puis de nos dirigeants
aussi
donc ce qui fait l'âme du dojo c'est le
professeur et puis l'équipe qui entoure
voilà et on le voit en jet d'eau
forcément on peut faire de belles
carrières quand on voit les athlètes
français de David Douillet à Teddy Riner
en passant du côté des féminin également
avec Lucie d'Écosse mais ce qui est
important de voir c'est dans les autres
disciplines par exemple en baskets ce
qu'on peut faire carrière après dans le
basket féminin même chose nous avons
posé la question l'agent d'Emilie Gomis
ce piliers de l'équipe de France de
basket Olivier Mazet pour lui il est
possible de faire carrière dans le
basket féminin aujourd'hui
par cet exemple il y a beaucoup d'autres
de jeunes de jeunes
jouer vers le sport qui est une passion
au départ de cette transcender et puis
de comment dirais-je de tutoyer un peu
les sommets par les sélections
nationales on est quand on est jeune par
l'obtention d'un contrat professionnel
et ensuite par la concrétisation hier
suprême quelle équipe de France avec les
Jeux Olympiques à mon avis le le Graal
sportif mais clairement oui aujourd'hui
il y a de perspectives pour des jeunes
joueuses qui voudraient qui voudraient
essayer en tout cas de de de se lancer
c'est aussi votre travail de les
accompagner vers le plus haut niveau oui
on essaye les structures se mettent en
place j'en profite d'ailleurs pour ce
Olivier Mazet que je connais bien qui
avait participé avec nous un petit peu à
notre aventure aussi il y a quelques
années donc je connais bien ils sont la
vie est tout à fait pertinent bien
entendu c'est une carrière de joueurs
aussi
dans le domaine donc nous on essaye
qu'on sent qu'il y a certains joueurs ou
joueuses qui ont un certain potentiel à
les pousser on a quelques joueurs
garçons on n'a pas eu de filles encore
mais dans le des garçons qui sont passés
professionnels maintenant et qui jouent
dans des clubs professionnels en France
donc on essaye de les de les faire
progresser le maximum après bien sûr la
structure fait que ils sont amenés à
aller dans d'autres clubs avec une
structure
pour les retrouver ensuite aux Jeux
Olympiques parce que forcément c'est un
travail qui débute dès le plus jeune âge
même chose en judo vous les accompagnez
vers le plus haut niveau on les
accompagne mais malheureusement au
département les gardent pas beaucoup ils
sont souvent aspirés par les gros clubs
franciliens entre autres dans le 92 et
le moyen dans le département dans le
département les gardes peu peut-être
avec le dojo à l'avenir peut-être à
l'occasion d'un reparler c'est notre
plus grand souhait une fois que le dojo
verra le jour le mot de la fin sera pour
les parents justement quel sport pour
votre enfant de basket féminin ou encore
du judo quelle discipline va vous
séduire en cette rentrée
bah il pratique le judo la natation
le basket du tennis pourquoi bah parce
qu'ils aiment le sport que ça soit la
natation ou le judo l'aide à s'exprimer
à avoir confiance en eux je pense aussi
ça donne de la confiance de l'assurance
et puis je pense que pour la santé c'est
c'est excellent aussi le respect des
règles
je sais pas le défi du foot et du tennis
pourquoi
c'est sport je sais pas j'aime bien
faire j'aime bien tirer ça dans des
balles alors c'est important oui pour
qu'il se dépense et ben je choisirais
qu'une idée peut-être un sport de base
le foot basket enfin c'est lui qui
décidera quoi donc voilà
c'est important que les enfants se
dépensent et on a une pensée forcément
pour les entraîneurs les éducateurs
parce qu'il faut les canaliser les
enfants parce que certainement sur les
forums des associations ce week-end je
serai toute la journée samedi au gymnase
Pierre de Coubertin Montigny alors pour
nous le judo on a un week-end chargé
puisque on a des stages nationaux de
rentrée donc sur l'Île-de-France samedi
et dimanche à Houilles pour les Yvelines
et dans l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines forum des
associations durant tout le week-end ce
8 septembre sauf du côté de
Magny-les-Hameaux il faudra attendre le
15 septembre vous avez encore le temps
de réfléchir un peu si vous hésitez
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau cette édition sera rediffusée à
19h 22h30 réalisation et Xavier Janin
prochain direct jeudi 18h invité
notamment Jean-Philippe Mallet député de
la 11e circonscription Jean-Michel
Coignard l'inspecteur de l'Académie des
Yvelines et Clément Gadea c'est
l'entraîneur de Florence sirogo engagée
aux Jeux paralympiques de Londres en
tennis de table nous parlerons de ses
résultats excellente soirée